hello and welcome to inside the Oscars
I'm Rachel Smith and today we're going
to show you who greets an Oscar winner
minutes after making their acceptance
speech
grab your credentials and join us inside
the press room
ladies and gentlemen Denzel Washington
Jennifer Knight so the press rooms are
where all the winners come after they've
received their award the general photo
room is the craziest room you have ever
been in the photographers are in risers
and they scream and yell the next room
the interview room it's made up of more
than 300 journalists from about 50
countries
I run the room and they walk in we
introduced them and questions start
flying up hands go up with their paddles
at our number and we'll start with 224
in the back so mister 150 next be here
for one and then to be nominated again
to win and then to perform sorry the
departed just won Best Picture
mr. Clooney then and see I win an Oscar
it's mr. Clooney you have the Oscar you
have the Grammy to to go for the ëgod
tonight might be out to you like I hate
to be our special night Beyonce d2 and
then I came really old girl I'm sorry I
did a shot before it's a really fun room
Helen Mirren was great when she went for
the Queen we had one of the French
outlets stand up and say I know you
speak French can I ask you said look
away I want on if they do don't hurdle a
psychology just hit them and he knew
that Helen Mirren's bit perfect French
usually winners you know are very open
about what they're just feeling and they
kind of sometimes continue what they
were saying on stage if anything like
the PI shows that you know we are
artists and not just technicians when
she called my name it was wedding slow
motion I
I didn't even get up or sit on it I
thought I was so old and jaded but they
call your name and you you just go into
sort of them
I don't know a white light or gone
stories you truly truly believe in
because then no obstacles to great it's
about so many people that went before me
that paved the way and people who are
fighting alongside with me and the ones
that will come along that whose path
will be indelibly easier that was great
when Martin Scorsese went for the first
time I mean I think the press stood up
and gave me standing ovation when he
walked in the room which is really nice
no good thing I didn't get it before
it's a good thing I waited and good
thing I you know yeah because maybe
maybe it would have changed the kind of
movies I made or something I couldn't
trust myself there shocked even if
everybody's been telling them they're
going to win it's still a shocking
moment I said that yeah I don't even
remember what I said I'm sorry they
talked about you know a moment they
experienced an unexpected moment I
thought I wasn't gonna make it up steps
a bad word but I can't say you know it's
great to see first-time winners and it's
really great to see somebody that's
maybe one once or twice before and you
know Meryl Streep I think there's room
for other people I'm frankly I
understand Streep fatigue and it shocks
me I think it's more exciting a surreal
the first time I was just taking
pictures with Halle Berry and she's
she's in the wishes you don't there's a
lot of moments that they that they share
with the press that the general public
usually doesn't get to see but the
wonderful thing about it is now the
public can't see it through
Oscar com want to see what happens
behind the scenes at this year's Oscars
visit Oscar comm for complete coverage
and look for more inside the Oscars
updates comin soon